welcome to the Michaela Peterson podcast
this is episode ten today's episode I
spoke to Dave Rubin Dave Rubin is the
host of the Rubin report the number one
political talk show on YouTube with over
1.3 million subscribers
the author of The New York Times
bestseller don't burn this book public
speaker stand-up comedian and
entrepreneur he toured with my dad in
over a hundred cities in 2018 and 2019
something we discuss a bit in the
podcast the most important thing we
cover though I believe is why people
should be courageous and how they can do
that given the current political
atmosphere I hope you enjoy it
[Music]
hi Dave welcome to my podcast it's good
to be with you Michaela we had some
technical stuff but here we are thanks
to the internet thanks to the internet
yeah it was a little rough to get set up
in Serbia but we're here I wanted to
start off by asking how do you get your
hair to look so good all the time
this is the first time I've been asked
that as the top question I do get that
question every now and again lately
which which as you know which i think is
why you're asking the question I've had
a little drama related to my hair over
the last couple of years I I haven't I
don't know anything about the drama
oh oh so I talked a lot about this with
with your dad and with your mom because
your dad was going through some
autoimmune stuff at one point and I know
you've obviously had a whole slew of
autoimmune things and I had my own bout
of it that's why I honestly thought you
were asking actually but god no no so
happens so this will be an interesting
transition to a bunch of other stuff
that I'm sure you're gonna want to get
into but about four years ago right as
my career was kind of blowing up like
right at the beginning of that when I
started telling people you know there's
something wrong with the left and what's
happening to liberalism I started
getting just like this endless slew of
online hate and being called a Nazi and
a bigot and a homophobe just like every
ridiculous thing that I could possibly
be called and friends were turning on me
in my book I talk about a girl who was
invited to my wedding who suddenly was
telling me I'm a Nazi I'm a bigot or
like just like horrific stuff and I
didn't realize this at the time but you
know I'm pretty calm on the outside this
is how I am if we weren't being
recording right now and if we were just
having dinner this is the center that I
speak at but I guess I do internalize a
lot of stress and in was the fall late
fall of 2015 I was getting my hair cut
and my my stylist jess who's a good
friend of mine she said you better look
at this and she pulled a mirror out and
she showed me the back of my head and I
had lost like a bunch of like probably
like two quarter sized chunks of hair
around my head and I went
the doctor I had no idea what was going
on I thought I had cancer or God knows
what and I was diagnosed with alopecia
areata which is an autoimmune disease
basically where I'm sure you're aware
where your your white blood cells start
attacking your hair follicles and they
have no known reason why it happens they
can only chalk it up to stress so I did
all the blood tests I did you know every
test you can imagine they said there's
nothing wrong with you you're not sick
but it's it's a stress-related sickness
and over the course of a few months I
lost probably like 45 percent of my hair
and then and then even worse and this is
where I think because I know some of the
stuff you've been through the treatment
that I ended up doing ended up being far
worse than that so I'm losing all this
hair and I'm going I'm doing my show I'm
putting on spray hair and and fiber
stuff and like like literally like
painting it on there was one night with
your dad in in Denmark where I actually
left my bag in in Stockholm the night
before I left my toiletry bag there and
I had to be onstage you know do it doing
our thing and I realized I didn't have
my spray-on hair like my paint he was
like paint almost and I had to run to a
store like I was freaking out I did not
want to be onstage with these huge
things and I ran there and if at the be
I don't know if there's any video of it
but at the beginning of that Denmark
show
I am freaking dripping in sweat because
I had to run and run right back to the
theatre anyway long story short I went
on a very experimental medication that
basically it's like putting poison ivy
on your head and it so that your white
blood cells instead of attacking your
hair follicles will attack the reaction
that like the the actual the itch
basically what that caused and this is
the crazy part what that caused was my
entire body except my face which is a
freaking miracle except my face my
entire body every inch of my body was
red and scaly and itchy and like pain
and I was like dry had sores on my head
dripping
I mean like a horrible gross stuff
that's not fun to talk about long story
short I did that for about four months
and then I realized that the treatment
was actually worse than losing my hair
I stopped doing that I significantly
change my diet to mostly a paleo diet
got rid of sugars and carbs and that
kind of stuff you know I do have like
one cheat day we kind of thing now but I
got off that and then the the reason
that my hair probably looks great and I
keep getting compliments on my hair now
is that I do PRP do you know what that
is platelet-rich plasma so what they can
what they do basically is I go once once
every two months they take my blood they
spin it in a centrifuge I'm sitting in
them in the room and it's just spinning
around they spin it for like 20 minutes
and then they inject my own plasma back
into my head and and that causes you
know whatever whatever it does it causes
hair growth and then I take you know I
take biotin and a couple other
supplements but I do credit actually
most of it to diet and just stop doing
things that are inflammatory so that's
really funny that that's the first
question you're asking me because I I
really don't know what I was expecting
at all yeah Wow well that's sucks I have
a lot more like since going through this
experience with dad and like the hell
he's been through from benzodiazepines
and all the stress he was under from
being called you know a Nazi by friends
basically yeah I have a lot more
sympathy for like public figures or
celebrities and the stress they're under
I remember like Kendall Jenner put out a
statement at some point she was like I'm
actually riddled with anxiety and the
response from everyone was like why you
live in a mansion with a pool and it was
like these people like it's hard being
stay it's hard being in public eye all
the time especially if you're in the
political realm look it's an it's an
inside job you know your life on the
outside it may look like you've got a
zillion houses in every car and
everything else but the the internal
stuff that we all struggle with whether
it's depression or a medical thing or
you know one of the things I talk about
in my book is that like you know you can
be closeted people think you could be
closeted it's about your sexuality but
you could be closeted about anything if
you're walking around with some secret
that whatever it is that you have you're
not sharing your beliefs with people
that stuff
starts to wear on you and and by the way
you know it's not just me and your dad
that's in our circles I don't I have
there's a couple other people that most
of your listeners will know that I don't
want to mention by name who have dealt
with autoimmune stuff when they're
getting hate you know like it's a real
thing because you don't know what to do
with it and then your body your body
just starts acting out your body's going
wait I got to get all this stress out
and then suddenly your hair is falling
out or whatever else so but you know I
remember when when we were on tour your
dad would say he would say it on stage
sometimes but he would talk about it a
little further when we were backstage
that he didn't like people thought he
liked being in the fight all the time
you know like if the New York Times came
out of the hit piece and then he
responded like people thought like
that's like the fun dance and he would
always say like you know I don't really
want to be fighting with people I'm
saying what I believe to be true but but
I'm not really doing this to fight or I
don't like the hit pieces or the rest of
it and I think that becomes
unfortunately just the way our media
works and everything else it becomes
this like offshoot of you know my
message is I want people to be treated
equally and and have open decent
conversation like I don't think that's
really controversial yet a certain set
of people think that apparently is
really controversial and just want to
just want to bludgeon you with hate and
and I think one of the things that that
your dad and the whole crew of people
have done really well is show that none
of us are perfect but if you keep going
through it it won't kill you even though
it's gotten pretty damn close in some
cases but but you have no choice because
otherwise it's like just live your life
on your knees and and I know I'm not
gonna do that yeah Wow well I'm still
kind of floored by your hair story
there's always like I'll just start this
podcast off and light you know I still
have I actually do still have like one
basically like quarter-sized spot back
here that were so my hair is a little
longer in the back but man it's it sucks
I mean you know you've been through so
much autoimmune stuff and dealt with all
the ways you know conventional
treatments and you've had surgeries and
and the stuff that you do with your diet
but like all of that stuff
like you you look like one thing on the
outside and if you feel like something
else on the inside when dozen those
things don't match it's tough it's very
tough and it's really horrible when I
mean it's bad enough feeling one way on
the inside and looking better on the
outside but when it starts to hit the
outside it's really scary and you don't
know how far it's gonna go right like
yeah alopecia
but then if that's sort of some sort of
inflammatory reaction like what's next
how do you get it under control and how
do you get it under control if you're
under overwhelming stress and oh maybe
like you said maybe you're not noticing
how much stress you're under right
because you get you know you do
something somewhat controversial or very
controversial to some people and then
you get a whole bunch of hatred on
Twitter and it's like oh I'll laugh it
off but you don't exactly know what that
does to you yeah well in a weird way in
a weird way it has almost helped me I
think in the long term and that's what I
mean by if you can get through it that
you will be stronger on the other side
because like you know there are videos
that I've done that are on YouTube where
you know I have college kids screaming
that I'm a Nazi and throwing stuff and
noisemakers and anti-fat aking people
and all all the stuff that that many of
us have been through and in all of those
moments when it's happening I'm actually
pretty calm like they're there there
were one or two moments over the last
couple years where I was genuinely
concerned there was one night with your
dad I think it was somewhere in the UK
where he was describing a biblical scene
and he couldn't quite remember the
imagery exactly and then suddenly we
heard like a crash in the back of the
theater and a guy was running to the
theater and kind of jumped started
jumping on stage and then he was tackled
but it turned out and this really shows
like the the the decency and genius and
and goodness of your dad I kind of froze
like I thought we were being attacked
and my reaction was just to freeze your
dad It was as if he saw it in
slow-motion it turned out that the guy
wasn't attacking us the guy had pulled
up the image on his phone of the
biblical scene and he wanted he wanted
to show it to your dad so that he and
you know the guy just like lost himself
like he just no doubt he just lost
himself but immediately your dad saw the
quick glimmer of it and said hey
everybody
down he wanted to show me the image it's
okay and yes security had to remove him
and I don't know what happened after but
like we don't none of us expect to be in
those odd situations just because you're
saying what you think is real and next
thing you know you've got people saying
horrible things value yeah we just
watched this is kind of out of the blue
but um I watched Magnolia yesterday with
my dad have you seen Magnolia you know I
saw it
that's Tom Cruise right that Tom Cruise
yeah he's in that the Philip Seymour
Hoffman is in it there's a whole bunch
of Julianne Moore but um anyway you
should watch it it's surreal it's
everything about that movie seems
incredibly unlikely and it was like well
is this just life is life just a series
of really unlikely events you just have
to get used to that or is that just some
people's lives I haven't I haven't just
I think I think I saw it way back when
maybe when it came out but I'll yeah
I'll watch it again okay well that was
an interesting way to get started about
your your book how's your book been
doing and people I asked my Instagram
following if anyone had questions for
you and one of the main questions was
what's your book about yeah so the books
doing great we released it on April 28th
which was you know smack dab in the
middle of the pandemic and you know
penguin Random House which is my
publisher we had all of these talks and
they wanted to delay it and they you
know nobody knew if even not only where
the store is not open but could books
even be shipped and would everything be
delayed and the whole thing and I just I
just kept saying we have to get this out
like I finished the book in July we
edited it in the fall and it's like when
you sit on those ideas forever it's like
they're it's almost like birthing
something I suppose right like you want
to get it out at this point it's it's at
their it marinated and it was like it
was time to get out so the book the book
absolutely crushed it we we you know we
hit the New York Times bestseller which
is a whole charade anyway that people
don't know about but it's like the
secret of the publishing world that it's
a charade but at some point if you sell
so well they can't screw you over
because they would you know they screwed
your dad over they didn't put him on and
they they even though the book sold like
7 million copies or something which blew
out every
you know in the last two years so they
pick who they want to screw but we sold
well enough that they felt I guess that
they couldn't screw us but what I'm most
proud of about the book honestly is that
the things that I talk about in the book
about what has happened with the radical
left the destruction of old-school
liberalism the destruction of freedom of
speech and that and that the left really
became everything it purported to be
against and that's not necessarily a
defense of all of the right but I come
from the left so that's what I know
you know everyone sees it now you know
the we called it don't burn this book I
probably should have called it don't
burn the store that this book is sold in
because we're watching stores burn now
you know so so that's what I'm most
proud of like for the people that are
confused about what is happening right
now if you if you're going whoa they're
tearing down monuments they're you know
they want to take down universities and
they're gonna come for Thomas
Jefferson's house in Monticello and
everything else there is a reason for it
and there were about 20 of us I would
say over the last five years online that
we're trying to fight it and we were not
treated particularly well by the media
but I will tell you this I don't think
I've said this publicly yet I just
signed the deal for the second book so
that'll be coming out in about a year
and a half and some excited imagination
yeah it was a real lesson and and you
know I don't want to bring everything
back to your dad but he was so helpful
for me and in making me realize that I
actually could do this and you know I
was it was about two minutes before we
went on stage in Oslo when I got the
call from my agent that the book deal
was done and the advance was was way
more than I thought it was gonna be and
I walked right into the into your dad's
dressing room and he's sitting there
with your mom and I said I said Jordan I
just got my book deal and I told him
what it was for and just because he
follows the 12 rules he was happy for a
friend he lit up huge smile he slapped
his hands like this he was in a swivel
chair
he completely swung around in the swivel
chair he got up he hugged me your mom
Tammy came over hug me David was with me
so we all kind of chatted for a little
bit and I I think back on that because
it's it is such one of the thing
that you know when you when you live up
to the things that you write about and
you talk about like be happy for your
friends when something good happens to
them not everybody was like that by the
way you know it means people get jealous
people get weird but yeah it's it's been
quite a ride Wow
how many cities did you open for dad in
so we did about a hundred and twenty
together you know some of them were
repeat cities so I think we did Toronto
like three times we did Stockholm twice
so it was you know probably around 110
cities total but it was you know 15 or
so countries and and it was just it was
just absolutely incredible because to
see thousands of people every night like
just come because they want to fix their
lives and they're doing it and then you
know go out sometimes your dad and I
would walk out to the crowd beforehand
we did that more at the beginning of the
tour when it was sort of still under the
radar and then as it exploded you know I
could do it a little bit more but you
know then it became for your dad it was
like he couldn't walk outside without
being completely mobbed but everywhere
we went you know we'd get off airplanes
and people would have been tracking
where we were gonna land and people
would be waiting at the airport and you
know your dad I never saw the guy be
rude to anyone ever like obviously you
know he's doing the the carnivore or the
the lion diet as it's now called and you
know so he'd have to eat wherever he
could eat and even if he was literally
even if he was literally just eating
some cut-up steak at the airport and
like starving if somebody came up to him
and said dr. Peterson I just want to
tell you no but he would stop he'd shake
their hand he'd ask their name like I
just saw that over and over again and
and I'm appreciative for it for a
million reasons but it it helped for me
it truly helped lay the groundwork so
that I could do what I do now like I'm
stronger and better now because of that
and yeah I owe the guy I know you
probably get sick of here and it's
sometimes from other people cuz for you
he's just dad but yeah that's true no
he's pretty cool like it was for the
most part of my life was like that's
just dad and I
thought like weirdly enough I thought my
mom was the weird one and she's kind of
weird but it turns out dad at dads
really the weird one
but no I think he's really cool so I
don't get tired of hearing it especially
after how rough this year has been yeah
yeah so speaking of people wanting to
improve their lives one the other main
question I got asked was given the
current political climate and it is
certainly scarier out there now than it
wasn't in 2016 2017 um what can like do
you have advice for the average person
on how to fight back or not be
influenced or not be scared in the
current political climate yeah it's a
great question and that really that is
the thrust of what my book is about I I
don't think that I'm somehow an
exceptional person for some reason I say
what I think right your dad I do
consider him to be an exceptional person
but what is that what is he doing in
essence he has a breadth of work over
decades and now he says what he thinks
all the people that we admire in the
world every hero in every movie that you
love what do they do they say what they
think and yet we live in a time where if
you live in the West you live in Canada
you live in the United States you are
free you are extraordinarily free and
yet we are the ones putting ourselves in
servitude we're the ones that are
silencing ourselves so I just did a
Prager you video a couple months ago
called the bravery deficit and I think
we have a massive bravery deficit now
that is that isn't to say that there
aren't good reasons for being quiet
right people are afraid of losing their
jobs people are afraid of losing their
friends they're afraid of being mobbed
on Facebook and Twitter that is all
legit so I'm not I'm not putting that
down but the problem is that the more
that good people just the average person
right you know who has let's whatever
the moderate political beliefs there are
the more that you're quiet you think
what you're doing basically is you think
oh I'm just gonna let this thing right
I'm gonna ride it out I'm gonna ride it
out and it'll skip over me but that is
simply not how this thing works
radical movement that is that is
spreading like a virus all over the West
it is preying on our silence so I'll
give you a good example I love love love
love love the Golden Girls okay every
Sunday for the last 10 years there's a
Golden Girls Marathon on TV land and
that's what David and I do for a couple
hours it's like the only television I
watch well you may have seen this week
that Hulu which also has the Golden
Girls they announced that they're taking
away a season 3 episode of The Golden
Girls because Rose who's Betty White and
Blanche rue mcclanahan they're in mud
masks and that's now blackface now the
entire episode actually yeah the entire
episode actually is about the fact that
Dorothy's son who's white is marrying a
black woman and the families come
together there's some funny jokes about
cultural differences in the rest of it
but the entire episode not only do they
get married at the end the entire
episode is about white people and black
people coming together and this is about
1987 or so now who decides to get rid of
it and it's like who who made that
decision and it's now yes did some
there's some executive somewhere that
had to sign something saying we're gonna
get rid of the Golden Girls because that
episode is is racist I mean are we gonna
take out ninety eight year old Betty
White at this point but the reason I
mention this is no one in their right
mind I could not find one person even in
the hellscape that is Twitter I could
not find one person that thought that
that Golden Girls episode was racist or
worthy of taking down but so how does it
happen
fear all it is is fear that a whole
bunch of us are quiet and then I don't
know if you ever saw the movie the
neverending story it's a great it's a
great childhood you know it's a kids
movie basically but there's a creature
in it the bad guy is a creature called
the nothing and what the nothing really
is is that we all all of us stop
imagining things we stop expressing
ourselves and that is what the
destruction of the world is and I really
believe that that's what's happening
right now
we're all afraid to speak we're all
afraid to share we're all afraid to to
go out
the edge and really experience what life
is which is figuring out what you think
and the more that we do that we give
room for this evil nothing to come and
next thing you know we're gonna take out
the Golden Girls and then by the way
you'd have to take out literally every
episode of Seinfeld you'll have to take
out every episode of Family Guy and
certainly The Simpsons and now The
Simpsons have said that they're not
going to have non black actors play
roles that are white even though the
Simpsons are yellow I mean the whole
thing is so stupid
but but I was not pleased about that
right right well he would talk about all
the time that the one thing he would
have you guys watch as kids was the
Simpsons and those yeah those formative
years you know that you take Simpsons
you know seasons four to ten roughly
that's like the best the best six years
of satire maybe in American history but
now suddenly you know who can't be a
character or at least can't be a
character voiced by white Hank Azaria
even though hank is actually going to
change his voice whatever I do
well Hank Azaria has said that he's not
gonna do it anymore
I've heard that they're not even gonna
have up who in the show I mean I'm not
sure if that part's true but think about
how insane this is every episode without
poo I know you've seen them I mean the
most seminal episode of a poo is is the
kwik-e-mart episode you know who needs
the kwik-e-mart right this is the famous
song who needs a queen right the whole
purpose of the episode is to show that
he's a true American he's a hard-working
immigrant there's other episodes where
he has an Indian wedding he talks to
Lisa about veganism he's accepted he's
probably the hardest-working best
citizen in all of Springfield you know
like the rest of the behindest yeah kind
of decent and everything else but they
want to destroy everything so just to
fully bring that full circle this
bravery deficit to answer your question
is what people need to do I know it
sounds scary but you've got to figure
out the spaces where you can speak up a
little bit more it doesn't mean just get
on Facebook and say you're a trump
supporter tomorrow although yes you're
allowed to support the President of the
United States that's not a crime yet as
far as I know but where whatever little
spaces you have in your life to speak up
a little bit more just because you're
your sis
sir you know is a radical leftist you
think by being quiet that's gonna make
it better but yeah you know what 20
years from now when you've lost all your
rights and now all the bad ideas of that
you know truly govern over you you're
gonna go ah I probably should have spoke
up more so basically if you're not
speaking up you're a frog in a slowly
boiling pot and it does not end well for
the Frog yeah okay that's kind of what I
think I asked I asked my dad this was
like some people what if they're in a
position where they're gonna lose their
job and all their friends and his advice
was slowly start to make other friends
right like don't be friends with people
who are going to dump you if you start
telling the truth those aren't friends
and by the way
well well by the way yes without
question you will lose friends if you
start speaking up against this thing you
will lose friends you can you might lose
family members
there's just note you might lose hair
there's just no doubt about it but what
you will find what you will find and I
know this with with absolute certainty
is if you start saying what you believe
and you lose some friends which you will
you will find better friends on the
other side because what you will find is
you will find people who value you for
your truth and and that is so what is a
friendship if a friendship is a one-way
street where they're allowed to say
whatever they want but you can't say
what you want that's actually not a
friendship the part that sucks
especially for for young people is that
it really is hard you're 18 19 20 to go
whoa like I'm gonna say something and
now my friends like your whole world is
wrapped up in your friends in a way I
think in a weird way this isn't totally
true and it depends on your temperament
but in a weird way I think when you're
older and you know maybe you have a
little more money in the bank or you
have a job or a family or something else
you might be willing to your whole world
isn't totally wrapped up in your friend
group and I think maybe it's sometimes
easier but but that partly depends on
just how you're wired I think yeah I
think that might be true because when
you're younger you're learning like
everything you're learning is from your
group of friends more or less or at
least the ages that you mentioned hmm
it's like you really take cues on how to
act from your friend group and so if
your entire friend groups as well you're
acting wrong even if you're saying what
you believe in then how are you supposed
to know whether you're right or wrong
right and think about think about the
option though so let's say your friends
8 out of 10 of your friends are sort of
these radical leftist Marxists you know
black lives matter or whatever this
thing is whatever you want to call it
well if you don't say anything and you
don't believe those ideas that you're
you're you're actually strengthening
those ideas and they're using their
using their power over you the power
that they have to silence you they're
using it as a hammer to just bury you or
a shovel to just bury you and I think
it's your job as a human being to fight
for what you believe in even if that's
different than what I believe in
you know I really believe that yeah yeah
I believe that too the other thing I've
realized in the last I don't know five
years or so is just because if you have
a thought and you feel like saying it
and you don't say it it doesn't
disappear like I thought well maybe I
shouldn't think we matter saying that
it'll just go away but it doesn't
everything you don't say is still there
somewhere and it'll come back to bite
you later I love that because not only
is that true but I think you could
probably even expand on that by saying
if you don't say it and if you just try
to bury it away it will either become
some weird twisted thing that will make
you act out in crazy ways you know
anything like crazy crazy ways
well the way I would the way I can sort
of personalize this to you is that when
I was closeted about my sexuality and
every every gay person knows this when
you have something about yourself that
you hide it's gonna come out in crazy
ways like if you're I mean without
getting like too deep into the weeds on
this like when I was closeted and people
didn't know like I had to meet people on
line to hook up I'm not proud of that
you know you mean and I'm not proud of
it or in a weird way I'm not ashamed of
it it just is what it is but I know that
wasn't me acting at my best right it
wasn't me being a full person that I am
now but what was the reason for it the
reason for it was I had thoughts I had
feelings that I couldn't get out and and
I felt I couldn't get out in like a
functional way right so then you do
what you have to do so whatever that is
and I think people think oh I could just
put that thing aside but once you put
that aside what you're really doing is
you're putting it in the basement of the
house and the house is your brain in
effect and if it's just sitting there
well it probably has an expiration date
and when that expiration date comes it
can infect the entire house yeah yeah I
agree
do you think part of the reason you're
so I completely agree with the bravery
issue like I'm I was really disappointed
when some of these blacklivesmatter
things started happening and some of the
people that were originally pros
free-speech kind of got sucked up into
it it was like ah you were okay and now
you're not okay I don't even know where
I was going with that
bravery yeah oh yeah
yeah I got I got okay yeah do you think
you having to go from closeted to not
closeted and talk about that do you
think that's what's triggered your like
bravery in this kind of situation I
think it's at least partly responsible
for it because I've been through it once
I was through it yeah I was through that
hell once like you know when you're
closeted like being closeted is like
it's like being a painter and just being
like I'm not gonna use blue like your
your set of emotions the set of things
that you're supposed to bring to the
world you're just saying I don't have
some of them or I have to hide some of
them it's not a good way to live like
there is nobody I can't imagine a human
being that has come out of the closet
and then is worse in the long term like
yes could it be worse in the short term
your family your friends like all of
that stuff even though that's actually
pretty rare even in more religious
communities these days that that's way
less rare in many ways you'll be propped
up by so many people but I'm not saying
it doesn't exist but I think I was
through that hell once like I did drugs
I shouldn't have done
you know I didn't hook up online thing
and like I did stuff that again it's not
about it's not about regret or or shame
or anything else because because I'm
okay now you know like so I just view I
view that as like the mix of stuff that
that got me here but I think sit
directly answer your question I was
through at once where I wasn't saying
what I felt and I know what it did to me
then so I could feel it happening again
you know there's a video that I did I
remember really the first video that I
did it was like it's probably bout six
years ago now where I first for the
first time was saying this thing about
what's happening on the left about free
speech I did this little walk and talk
video David held the camera I was just
walking in an alley just saying what the
hell is going on here and the video kind
of blew up and I thought whoa all I did
was just say what I'm thinking that's it
that's it you know and and then from
that it started giving me more courage
and more courage and more courage and
one of the cool things that I see now is
I see you know every time someone comes
out of somewhere that suddenly they're
having an issue around free speech so
whether whether it's your dad originally
with the whip see I always forget it see
17 or 16 16 16 whether it was your dad
then I didn't know him before that or
whether it's Lindsey Shepard up at
Laurel University wilfred laurier
or whether it was James d'amour or Brett
Weinstein or any of these people that
just suddenly started saying what they
think they see the monster attack them
one of the things I'm most proud of is
that I've been able to offer them some
space usually physically in this room
but now we do it you know usually by
Skype to express their feelings and then
what that does is it makes all the
people at home go oh there are other
people like me and then the hope the
hope is that then those people start
doing it and then you don't know what
signals you're spreading across the
world and actually that was one of the
things that your dad would often talk
about in his talks that especially with
social media you have no idea what your
power is in the world none of us have
any idea the fact that we can think
something that you can think
thing right now put it out on Twitter
and watch it spread and then maybe you
don't see the full repercussions because
you know you say okay I got a thousand
retweets in two thousand right so that's
nice but from all the other people that
spread that in another way that you
might have sparked some interesting
thought that will fight and that's why
even right now you know everybody is
sort of crazed about politics and
everything else but I'm in a weird way
the silver lining that I see is that
people are waking up people are waking
up you know like they're they're going
what really is happening here and that's
why I don't believe polls anymore or
anything like that because I'm like yeah
there's just no way to gauge really
what's happening right now yeah and it's
interesting going back watching some of
the interviews with people in the I
guess IDW in 2017 where the journalist
on the other side would be like oh
that's a conspiracy what you're talking
about
is this now like not to say I told you
so because you don't really want this
happening because it's significantly
worse than it was two years ago or even
six months ago although everyone was
distracted by the corona virus six
months ago but it's kind of
i-told-you-so
do you think there's any way back from
this or is North America doomed I would
go a little bigger than North America is
the West doom do you know like the
general the general Australia they're
involved yeah is the general idea of the
West doom we'll look well first off I
would say I I always describe myself I'm
a world weary optimist so I'm an
optimist in that I don't think I could
do what I do if I didn't believe we
could fix things because otherwise what
the hell am I talking about all day long
and why am I talking to these people if
we couldn't make them better but I would
say I'm world weary in that I think
above anything else I really do consider
myself a realist I don't I'm sort of
like a subtle dreamer but I'm a realist
and that you can't just make the world
the way you want tomorrow just because
you want it that's what that's what the
Marxists the progressives are doing
they're just like let's burn the whole
frickin thing down and we're gonna make
it better tomorrow even though these
people have never accomplished anything
right it's and of course it's a lot
easier to burn
to build you know I would say your dad
would get this question a lot and I
think his answer sometimes would be
something like this he would say you
know in essence you have to let these
ideas burn like sort of burn to the
ground because then maybe a phoenix can
rise from the ashes I think the real
question about the secondary question
there is what does that burn to the
ground destruction look like like does
that really does that take out every
institution and you know it's like at
this point in the West like does the New
York Times deserve our respect anymore I
don't think so
does Harvard deserve our respect anymore
I don't think so
so but the question is all right well if
all of these things burn and by the way
whether you and I would would like them
to burn or not it's too late social
justice as an idea is a virus what is a
virus a virus is very easy to catch and
very hard to get rid of right that's
kovat right it's very easy to catch and
very hard to get rid of these ideas of
social justice that's why they infect
young people they say they all sort of
sound right everyone's racist you're
gonna not be racist
your grandparents must have been able
matter but all the slogans what are they
really good at black lives matter well
you don't want to say black lives don't
matter so then you you accidentally say
it as if it means something or
progressives whatever what a lovely
phrase I'm a progressive I'm for
progress but you don't want to be for
progress when progress is going to take
you off a cliff what you want to be for
is equality but they're not even for
equality of course they're for equity
which are which are very different
things therefore equality of outcome so
the real issue is how much destruction
does it cause I say this I think that
the United States has a better defense
mechanism than any other Western country
not only do we still have the First
Amendment for now so our right to free
speech but we have you know the idea of
the American you know the snake flag
don't tread on me the idea that
Americans are armed that Americans you
know the the the stereotype of an
American you know get off my lawn and
you know keep the government out of my
life and all that we
really have that we're in many ways they
don't have that in a lot of European
countries they don't have that there
there is a deeper connection between the
government and the people sort of that
keeps them intertwined where we're kind
of like I don't want the government in
my life how did our country get founded
in the first place you know no taxation
without representation so there's a
beautiful thing here in the United
States that I think can help stand up to
it without going too far down the
political rabbit hole I mean the bizarre
truth right now is that Trump is I would
say basically a necessary evil at this
point if he wasn't around fighting this
thing imagine if it was just a regular
Republican in charge right now trying to
fight this thing imagine if it was Mitt
Romney or John McCain who you know I
think they're both they probably McCain
was and and Romney is I think they're
probably both decent human beings but
you know damn well everyone knows this
any any pick any other Republican Marco
Rubio or Ted Cruz or whoever they could
never stand up against this thing Trump
for whatever reason he's got all you
know crazy hair and orange skin and he
tweets like a crazy person it is his
effect is weird and all that stuff for
some reason he can stand up to this
thing so one of my frustrations you just
mentioned how oh some people are like
coming you know two years ago they were
blowing it out of proportion now they're
you know thought we were blowing it out
of proportion now they're coming around
one of my frustrations now is I know a
lot of public people that on the DL if
I'm about to dinner it now or talking to
them privately they're kind of into
Trump because they know he's doing their
dirty work but then they spend all day
on Twitter attacking him because they
still want to go to nice parties and I'm
sort of over that part of life like I
got David's a great chef we're okay here
I got friends so so I'm not as fearful
as that but that's one of the things
that's really frustrating me these days
that I think a lot of people they subtly
like what Trump is doing maybe not the
whole package but like that part of it
but then they spend all day oh but I'm
so much better you know but it's like
man he's doing the dirty work for you
guys he's also this like life is so
ridiculous right now it
could be in the movie Magnolia in order
to counteract how ridiculous it's
getting on the left you might have to
have someone as ridiculous as Trump
tweeting out what he tweets out fighting
like you said the monster that's that's
there it makes sense if you think about
life as a movie yeah well it also it
also makes sense if you just think that
there's a certain balance in the world
these guys have gone off the deep end
and what what I'm actually worried about
more than anything else and this
actually is another idea that your dad
would talk about sometimes is that as
the left goes bananas you know right now
like I'm not that concerned with the
right in general I think there's
something interesting happening on the
right I think conservatives are a little
more open-minded than they've been you
know I have a lot in common with most
libertarians I think the magg accrue I
don't think they're racists I really
don't now is there some far-right which
really is far left because it's
collectivist is there some white
nationalist problem on the right well
yes it's a tiny little thing that is no
institutional power I don't think Trump
is part of it I don't think Tucker
Carlson is part of it and because it's
collectivist it's actually left not
right but that that's a whole separate
issue if you were if you were really
far-right that would mean that you're
just the ultimate individualist meaning
you don't want government so you know
that's like you want to live in Mad Max
or something which i think is kind of
fun to talk about but I don't think it's
that real yeah okay you know who you
should have on your podcast if you want
to talk about that kind of stuff do you
know Michael malleus I've heard of him
all right I'm gonna loop you guys in I
he's like one of the great sort of
anarchist thinkers that we have he's
totally fun you'll you'll love him like
fun yeah you'll love him and and I love
that intellectually I love that exercise
like how much of it can we can we
destabilize and all that it's not
exactly what I think is a functional
society but it's like fun to think about
but in essence one of the things your
dad would talk about is that if you
would just keep calling Trump racist you
keep calling Trump Nazi you keep calling
half the country bigots blob up trust me
this is not the bigot when when the
bigot comes you guys aren't even gonna
you'll have cried wolf so many times
that nobody will know and that's the one
that I'm worried about if the left goes
completely bananas and Trump can't stand
up to it he's just not enough and he
gets thrown under the bus by Mel you
know well-meaning conservatives or
something like that
that what comes after him will be much
worse it will actually be a far-right
closer to what there is across Europe
which usually has sort of an identity
Rhian right to it like a white
nationalist right we don't really have
that in America and I just think if
Trump can't hold the line then nobody
can so we have to be careful what we ask
for here yeah we'll end up with a
Dolores Umbridge I just I just watched
Harry Potter she's a prime minister of
Croatia who is that okay I know I know
you have to go right away so I want to
ask you just a couple more questions
about what your day looks like as a very
productive human I've been asking a lot
of people I have on my show like what's
your sleep schedule like we kind of
covered what your diet looks like how
many hours you worked you exercise so
that kind of thing just so we all have
an idea of what they can emulate yeah I
like that you're s in that question
because I think right now with COBIT and
everything else and we're all trapped at
home and all this weird stuff like one
of the things I've been saying for last
couple months is what a great
opportunity to really get that stuff
lined up like get how you eat lined up
get how you exercise lined up your skill
set like we you know I'm in LA so I
don't have a huge property here but we
lined our house with planters and I'm
growing all sorts of food now which I
which I love doing and like I've got
tomatoes and cucumbers and peppers and
all kinds of stuff outside and broccoli
and and and I like doing it also because
I'm not on my phone it's like nice for
my brain as far as my as far as my day I
usually I don't set an alarm unless I
have like a three o'clock a.m. you know
radio hit or something but I usually am
up by 6:30 the first thing I do always
like I usually pee and then after I pee
I wash my hands and then I just have a
glass of water like not even a full
glass like room temperature like maybe
half glass of water just to like kind of
get my system alive I do French press
coffee I do
mushroom supplements and collagen powder
and that can usually get me going for a
couple hours I used to be a big
breakfast person occasionally I'll have
some oatmeal or some eggs but not that
much usually not that often anymore I
kind of wait till about noon as far as
exercise I have an elliptical machine in
the house I try to do it like an hour
every other day
not even that crazily intensive but just
to just break a sweat and and kind of
feel right I try not to I talked about
this in the book actually I try not to
have my phone in my bedroom I think
that's actually one of the key things
because because the idea that the last
thing you look at at night potentially
is Twitter or even if it's Instagram or
whatever that you're looking at that
screen right before you go to bed and
that that then you could wake up and you
know that I could scroll my Twitter feed
and have a million genderless anime
Marxist avatars tell me that I'm an
[ __ ] like it's not a good way to
start the day so we don't we also don't
have a television in our bedroom like I
I think the bedroom is for two things
you could probably figure out what they
are that's what the bedroom is for so no
TV in our bedroom I try to keep the
phones out of the bedroom I you know
when I take my dog for a walk we never
take our phones so for me just because
of this world that that you know you and
I live in that more and more people are
getting sucked into the endless online
world I think figuring out those moments
of disconnect is is deeply deeply
important I don't know if you saw the
movie The Matrix but you know the idea
really of the matrix is that humans are
our carbon bodies are our bodies will
basically just be the batteries for the
digital world and and in many ways
that's what we're becoming we spend
hours and hours and hours staring at
screens giving our minds and our ideas
and all this stuff just to the digital
world and it's like man if you spend
more than 12 hours a day 12 hours in one
second a day doing that well then which
world is real and I think this is going
to be one of the like biggest things
that we're gonna have to grapple with as
humans going forward there's going to be
a material
world the world that we have known for
thousands of years well for millions of
years but you know with human recorded
history thousands of years and then
there's going to be this digital
frontier that is going to be very very
different you know it's sort of like
ready player one or the matrix I mean
there's a lot a lot of sci-fi movies on
that but I think doing a couple things
that disconnect you for me at least
that's like the most important thing
right now yeah yeah yeah well that's
kind of aligns with what I do I try and
sleep with my phone is on my bedroom too
because yeah waking up and going on
Twitter first thing is a sure way to
like destroy your day yeah but thank you
very much Dave I wish we had more time
yeah but I'm sure I'll I'll talk to you
soon where can people find you and where
should they go to buy your book yeah
well you can go to don't burn this book
dot-com to check out the book and Reuben
report.com is the is the Reuben report
community or youtube.com slash Reuben
report and and we're gonna get you on my
show to talk diet and and all that stuff
because I know what it did for you and
then that was the funny thing when when
I started telling your dad about what
was going on with my hair and everything
else that was one of the things that
kind of really brought us together
because it's like you know when we're
public people and people are being nice
to us and saying nice things and we're
shaking hands and all that stuff that's
like one version of us but then you know
we'd be sitting in like you know often
these theaters even if they're
spectacular theaters the green rooms
you've been there the green rooms are
kind of dumpy and you know there's
nothing luxurious about them and we'd be
sitting in these tiny rooms like kind of
talking about what we're struggling with
or what we're dealing with and and all
sorts of stuff you know like we really
got to know each other in a you know
what I now look back on in like a very
special way and the diet stuff was was a
big part of that so I want to get you on
to talk about the Lyon diet I don't know
that I could do I we do a lot of steak
now and I'm doing a lot of grilling but
I don't know that I can do full-on
full-on lion it's not ideal like it's
not like anyone on the line diet is like
yes this is how I've wanted to eat for
my entire life cut out all the cake like
no one wants that
and hopefully I think in the next couple
of weeks I'm going to try reintroducing
some some plant food which made some of
my
some of the people who follow me you're
like how could you do that I was like
you know what I liked apples I did it
just made me ill for a while but maybe
they won't anymore so by the time I come
on maybe I will be an apple and steak
diet who knows we should just have a
plate of steak and apples in front of
each of us and we'll see what kind of
hate that unleashes into the world yeah
as I'm sure it doesn't matter what we
talk about it'll unleash hate somewhere
okay I have a few more questions yeah
I'll try to be I'll try to be brief okay
okay this is this is completely
different
yeah but what was your favorite guest
that you've had on and your most
challenging to answer that yeah yeah
well I can I can I'm my boss so the
chances I fire myself are pretty slim
well look I've said a lot of nice things
about your dad so the the true answer to
this is that when I had your dad for the
first time in studio because the first
time I interviewed him was on Google
Hangouts I had just moved into this
house I didn't our internet connection
was bad I didn't have a studio yet I it
was when nobody knew who he was also it
was right at the beginning of the stuff
and and our I couldn't quite hear him
and the video was freaking out and I
when I go in when the women when it
ended when it ended I said today but I
said that guy is either the most
incredible thinker I have ever spoke to
or completely crazy and and that's sort
of that's sort of what I felt and maybe
maybe maybe anyone good is both right
but but when I sat with him in person
the first time and I really got to do
that that dance that you can do as an
interviewer and then even before your
dad and I went on tour we did a couple
college gigs together and a few other
things and and that sort of expanded on
it but I so I would say that because
especially because because truly I mean
he became the world's most important
public intellectual and I think a lot of
that was birthed right here in my garage
like that's that's pretty cool you know
like so I think that's the that's one
answer I would say the what was the
second part was it was the the most
struggle the most I struggled
challenging yeah most actually most
challenging so so this is sort of
interesting there you know this guy's
stefan molyneux yeah yeah
the UJ he just got banned from YouTube I
think in the last couple days and he
does a lot of self yeah and he does a
lot of self-help stuff and and there is
he's focused on race and IQ which is
just not an issue I really it's not
something that I care about or think
about or anything like that
when I had him on I really wanted to
make sure I did an appropriate interview
because those topics are so fraught with
peril and dangerous and bring up so many
things and the question that I kept
asking him which I felt was the right
question was why do you care about this
race and IQ like why is it so important
to you I felt it was the right question
I've gotten a tremendous amount of hate
for that I know I've lost gigs for even
talking to him when the New York Times
wrote that piece on the IDW the big
piece
they basically threw me and Rogan under
the bus because Rogan had talked to Alex
Jones and I had talked to him but you
know as an interviewer if you're not
going to talk to people that that might
be noxious you're probably not much of
an interviewer yeah yeah okay that's
interesting okay are you religious I
think I there's some news went around at
some point that you went from atheist to
not atheist at some point am I wrong
about that so I I grew up in a mostly
secular Jewish home which is sort of
like that there was there was like a
belief but it you know it's a little
different than sort of like a
traditional Christian belief where you
have to have like a personal
relationship with God in that sense
they're like the Jewish tradition is
more of like there's like a struggle
with God there's like you you debate
about all of these things that's sort of
what I grew up with and then I had had
early on in my show with slew of like
Big Time atheists on my show so Sam
Harris and Michael Shermer and Peter
Bogosian and a bunch of other guys and
then one day I kind of just said I was
an atheist I I didn't fully mean it
exactly but I I meant more like when I
said it I think I meant more like I'm a
skeptic per se I didn't fully mean like
I have no I have a complete lack of
belief then what happened was two years
ago you know I do this off the grid
August where I have no phone no news
nothing I literally lock my phone in a
safe and I've done it for three years
I'm gonna do it again this year and this
year is gonna be bananas because the
news is so crazy can you imagine I'm
gonna go off on August first come back
on September what will happen we could
be in the middle of World War three who
knows but two years ago and I did it we
went away for a little while and one of
the thoughts you know because I gave my
my brain room to like just be one of the
thoughts that consistently popped in my
head was that I do believe in something
else I I do believe in something outside
of myself and and I came back online and
I mentioned that and then suddenly I was
getting a ton of hate from the supposed
to taller an atheist community they were
suddenly all angry at me even though
even though I said I wasn't saying you
have to you have to pray you have to go
to church or temple or anything I was
just saying I personally believe in
something outside of myself and then I
go into this a bit in the book but your
dad did move me on on the importance of
biblical stories and that there are
truths that have been time-tested truths
throughout generations that have kept
society together so you know I know what
your when your dad we get asked some
version of this or do you believe in God
he would always say I hate this question
because it's it's so hard to do and you
know even if we did this for three hours
it's hard to do but I would say I
absolutely believe in in something
outside of myself which we can call God
and we can all debate what that specific
word means but I think our founders in
America got it right there are god-given
rights the state did not make me free it
can take away my freedom but it did not
make me free it is your you are free as
a human being your birthright is freedom
and that is not a that is not because a
human gave it to you it's because God
gave it to you why do we believe that
the little guy can beat the big guy why
do I always attack Google when they
crush my videos well you know there's a
story David beat Goliath right there are
time-tested stories that I think have
value that that actually this is
probably the best way I can answer it
it's a functional version of belief some
people need a belief that is like sort
of transcendent and deeply spiritual
that's not exactly what my my set of
beliefs are I don't think it's exactly
what what your dad's are but obviously I
don't want to speak for him mine are
more functional it's like we need God
and a set of things outside of ourselves
to organize a society and if you don't
believe that well look what's happening
right now
what do you think that these Marxists
believe in these communists and
collectivists believe in many ways we're
at the end of secularism right now
liberalism has basically been demolished
and what do you get at the end of it you
get an absolutely destructive force and
what will be the one thing that will
stand up to it it's gonna be some
religious and conservative institutions
I think that's a reason enough to be a
believer I thought I was well I was
agnostic forever in that and then I did
shrooms way too many times no idea of
like there's definitely things out there
so I don't know what I am now I have
done shrooms way too many times myself
yeah that definitely helps with the
whole atheism thing I think okay okay
last question so you were under while
you're still under and just being in the
public eye puts you under a lot of
stress
do you have tactics you said diet and
things but do you have anything else
that you're using now or that you're
trying to put in place for yourself in
order not to be overwhelmed by stress
well it's funny just as you asked that I
took a deep breath I don't know if you
noticed I try to take a deep breath
every now and again I mean literally
just taking a deep breath every now and
again that's not you know obviously
there's there's yoga reasons to do that
and you know people that are into
meditation and all that I'm not
particularly into that stuff actually
but I do find every now and again if you
just every couple hours if you just
freaking take a deep breath actually not
that it's the most brilliant thing in
the world but when I sat down
with Eckart Tolle you know he talked a
lot about that that just just that alone
can calm you down so I would say it's
the diet stuff you know I don't do drugs
anymore really
you know I smoke pot every now and again
but truly it's it's I take like a puff
before you know at like 11 o'clock at
night I watch an old episode of The
Simpsons and I pass out like that really
is it I don't so I don't do any any
other drugs I don't I like wine but I
don't really abuse alcohol so like I
could have two glasses of wine or it was
my birthday last week I had a couple
more but I can't remember the last time
I was like stupidly drunk so I don't
wake up with hangovers you know I think
doing things that basically make your
life right I have a pretty banged up
knee at the moment but I try to go shoot
hoops sometimes even just by myself
just to just do things that'll keep you
out of the fight you know like I feel I
think everyone feels right now that
we're just we're in a fight at all times
politics is now everywhere you turn on
ESPN it used to be sports now they're
talking about racial justice this thing
has infected everything you know
McDonald's Twitter handle now is black
lives matter it's like I want a burger
from you not a message about whatever
that message is like everything has
caused us to feel that we're in we're
just in the belly of the beast all the
time so whether it's controlling your
phone whether it's controlling your
appetite whether it's gardening you know
I think I've told you David's a really
great chef but I've started cooking more
because I think if you do a few other
things that just expand your skill set
you don't know where that will lead so I
know none of that's like a magic bullet
but I think I think collectively they
all kind of form something that's pretty
decent yeah okay that's all good advice
thank you Dave very much for coming on
yeah it was my pleasure yeah well I'm
glad that I'm glad that you're doing so
well I'm glad that your mom's doing
great last I heard I'm glad to see your
dad around
and you know I'm so glad like this last
year was so awful I told you I like I
watched magnolias yesterday with dad and
it was just like yep just life like how
can terrible things just repeatedly
happen over and over and over again but
I think we're getting out of it so well
you know you got to do fingers crossed
well fingers crossed for sure but you
know you got to do which I'm sure it's
probably on your list of things to do
with your dad but you just got a rent
Groundhog Day and I know how much he
loves it
I know how you know that was one of the
questions we would get a lot in the Q&A
is we'll do that next yeah well he would
get one of the questions would be what
it was either what's your favorite movie
or especially people say what's your
favorite comedy and and he would always
mention Groundhog Day because it's so in
line with Jungian philosophy and so many
of things you know correcting you don't
keep making the same mistakes right like
you make it once you make it twice but
now start figuring it out so you could
do that and then just do due season for
Simpsons with him you guys will you guys
will be great in no time you know season
30 we just watched season 30 season 30
isn't half bad for the Simpsons a little
weird yeah season 30 like we just
skipped to the end but um it's pretty
good compared to like it was a little
iffy for a while maybe like 15 years
there but like season 30 is pretty good
if you're interested well it's funny
because you know when you love something
like the way you guys obviously love the
Simpsons the way I love it it's like I
don't want it to end right but at the
other hand it's like they're just sort
of bludgeoning it to death but that's
nice to hear all right season 30 already
was pretty good I'll give it a go I'll
give it a go
okay okay well I'll talk to you soon
Dave all right thanks Michaela
[Music]
you